hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm gonna answer questions from
one of my newsletter leaders Harriet who
is in Ghana and they're setting up a
nonprofit organization to help raise
funds startup loans for people in Ghana
women entrepreneurs in Ghana who want to
start up their own business as a way to
you know get out of poverty be able to
enrich their lives hire people and you
know build a new life for themselves and
she's trying to raise funds one of my
advice on how to do it so Harry I don't
know the whole process about raising you
know money for a non-profit in in Ghana
but what I do have some experience on is
with using services like Kiva so we work
with Kiva to give micro loans to
entrepreneurs across Africa we've raised
thousands and thousands of dollars help
in doing it and what really attracted me
to it was how easy it was to be able to
lend money and see that you're helping
people so there may be a whole bunch of
government grants you can go after loans
my experience is more from the
individual investor somebody wants to
give back so if you're targeting North
American audience who feel like they
want to do something helpful and and
help other entrepreneurs grow their
businesses that could be an interesting
market that's guys like me and a whole
bunch of other people who you know want
to find a way to give back meaningfully
and so we loan out thousands of dollars
to Kiva so there's another market for
you to be able to go after what I would
suggest doing is you need to create a
website show the people who you're
helping and that's one of the great
things that'll keep as you can see who
you're helping you know you take a
picture of them and hopefully it's a
smiling picture I know there's some
cultural differences where it's not
always easy to get a smiling picture but
for us in North America you know we like
seeing people with smiles it makes us
more willing to want to work with
somebody and help that person out so you
want to try to take smiley pictures tell
us what the money is gonna be used for
try to tell a story to you know pull out
the heartstrings a little bit and make
us want to help out so it's not just you
know here's an entrepreneur Susan who
needs 500 bucks to start her business
you want to tell her story say you know
why she wants to start
some of the hardships you've been
through any family information that you
want to share all that stuff is great
and ties the the readers closer to that
person and makes them want to help so
you want to tell the story have updates
so tell people how they're doing as you
raising the money or as the money's been
raised if you're paying it back then
have quick updates to show how she's
doing that's also fantastic and keeps
people more motivated want to help other
people I'd be great to you with a share
through social media I think that's
something keep up you do a better job of
so whenever you give a loan to somebody
it could be integrated with your
Facebook or your Twitter account to say
I just helped you know whoever and I
raise 100 bucks - 25 bucks or whatever
it is to help them get started that'd be
great to get integrate with somebody's
Twitter feed as an example so those are
a few ideas I definitely model Kiva or
there may be a way for you to just work
with Kiva and that could be an
interesting opportunity as well they
basically work with different
organizations to give out the funds so
that could be an opportunity for you to
get access to a large pool of capital
and we only work with entrepreneurs for
an Africa through Kiva so if you do get
on there let us know and hopefully we
can send a little bit of money your way
to help your organization girl so I hope
that helps if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to make more of these
videos for you guys and if you like the
video and you have something to say
about it please leave a comment
underneath if you have a question or
some other advice please leave a comment
underneath and we'll see you in the next
episode
you